wait so Erica Banks and you got you guys
have a conflict this this season because
she watched the season it's like not but
it's given watch the season and you'll
you'll see what's happening here it's a
lot of girls fighting for that position
and the position is mine and there's a
lot of girls fighting for it and I am
who else is rapping on the show that's a
woman um you have
spice she's an international artist you
have who else is I was about to be Shady
I'm working on the level of shade that I
give so I'm gonna minimize this about 40
you have uh Carly Red on there still and
she's rapping now okay so you have her
it's I don't know it's just weird
everybody's like once they got the bag
they just said I actually want to rap
now
it's weird